Just outside Ciudad Juarez.
And this is the last train
stop for this freight train
that's eventually
going to head into the city.
And you can see already
dozens of migrants
in several of these cars on top of them
all about.
They're asking us if we have water,
we have food.
We climb on
the train slowly starts up again,
heading north.
We meet migrants from all over Honduras.
And this is from Honduras
originally and wants to go to the US.
Felipe and Marcela from Colombia,
also hoping to enter the U.S.
I asked her why the U.S.
she said to have a better future.
Omar from Venezuela
in Baltimore,
is trying to get to Baltimore, Maryland.
We rode for an hour.
They've been on here for days.
12 days for Roberto and his family.
I'm here, man.
He's with his dad and his sister.
I had no role.
You know, he's all done.
She has.
And the door says they've been attacked.
They've been robbed.
Describes a really treacherous track.
Part of the train journey north for some
is on what's called La Bestia The Beast.
It's also known
as the train of death
and often controlled by cartels.
Roberto wears a facemask
to not infect the others, tells me
he got sick early on in his travels
There's a lot of them have been sick.
And over the journey,
they believe these two kids, young ones.
He tells me his two toddlers nearly died.
So we sent them back
with family in Honduras
as he continues on.
They stand, sit and sleep
on metal construction beams
covered in plastic, dirty clothes.
And cardboard
used to make it as comfortable
as possible.
The heat and sun brutal at night.
It's the cold and wind.
The smells arrange
sewage at times and burning trash
as we drove past
what appears to be an incinerator.
Their souls worn down on
and through your body.
Is
just legal.
It's very dangerous for women, too.
And they said food
is is just really scarce right now.
If you call me that dog.
Not anymore.
I wish to see him again.
Forget the walking down the aisle.
Omar spent four days on board already.
Food is run out.
He showed us the little water
he has left.
And the documents.
He clings to keeping secured in plastic
the gates.
But the main thing is,
I don't know where they're
going to settle for
so long as he's ready
for all the different situations
that would allow you to enter the U.S..
And he's got it printed out in Spanish,
and he's got it the address.
And so I'm able
to have his friend in Baltimore
that he hopes to get to us
said, and that gives you money
for days on the train for him.
He said the first day
you just got really sick
because the sun was just so strong
and now he's making sure to keep covered
as much as possible.
He wants to go to New York for Omar.
It's a familiar journey.
He left Venezuela six months ago,
already expelled once from the U.S.
for trying to cross.
He'll try again when you get a legal
whether legally
or illegally, he will cross, he tells me.
I ask him if he's hopeful
that that is easy for him, which I fear.
I've got a lot of faith, he tells me.
Ultimately,
he hopes to get the money
sent back to his kids in Venezuela.
Which is a good idea
because
as we pull in this
year that Juarez, about 25 miles
still from the border
wall with El Paso,
we and the others climb out
and that's it.
You can see
almost everyone now getting off.
It's basically the last stop.
Omar among the last off
carrying his only belongings and somehow
a smile.
I mean, at
some point
is planning to cross immediately
He ran across highway, not around.
Then he went up
and we're giving you a live
look right now
at the destination
for those migrants who are on board
that train along with us.
And you can see some changes
that we've noticed in the past hour
or so, Jake.
We've shown you this spot
over the past couple of days,
but there's two large groups now.
And it seems that Texas National Guard
along potentially with CBP are separating
single men to the far side
and then closer to where we are.
Mostly families are together.
And some of these families
we're starting to see
take their belongings
and toss them into
a big essentially dumpster.
And that's
usually typical of what happens
before they're going to be processed
and allowed into the U.S.
to go forward with their claims of asylum
with the single men
who have been taken aside
and put into another group.
It's very likely
that if
it's following any sort of precedents
that we've seen in the past,
they'll be brought back over the border
from the U.S. right here to Mexico.
And that's part of the deportation
expulsions
that we've seen under Title 42.
So it's very possible
that's exactly what's happened to that
group, Jake.
All right.
David Culver
with some important reporting.
Thank you so much.
Joining me
now to discuss
is blasting as yet, though.
He is the assistant secretary for border
and immigration policy
at the Department of Homeland. Security.
Thank you so much for joining us today
on such a busy day.
What are you?
What are your intelligence sources
telling you
about how many migrants the U.S.
could be encountering daily?
Well, we've already heard it's
been over 10,000 a day.
Are you expecting after midnight tonight?
15,000. 20,000 a day?
What are you expecting
Yeah.
Thank you very much,
Jake, for having me on the show today.
Look, we know that
there are many thousands of migrants
you know, in Mexico and along the transit
routes coming north,
you know, seeking to access our border.
We have been working
closely with our regional partners,
including the government of Mexico,
in order
to, you know, increase enforcement
on those routes.
You know,
we have been averaging
about 10,000 encounters a day.
The last few days,
you know, this is, you know,
what we've been planning for,
frankly, for the better
part of two years.
We always knew that
the days
leading up to the lifting of Title 42
and immediately
after it were going to be challenging.
And that's
why we have been,
you know, relentlessly
focused on preparing for it for so long.
You just said and Secretary,
my caucus has previously said
you've been preparing for this
for nearly two years.
If that's the case,
why are you only just now
surging these people, U.S.
officials, to help out at the border?
And why hasn't there been a bigger effort
over the last two years
knowing that this day would come
to better convey and better prevent
all of these undocumented
individuals from coming into the country
So we
have, in
point of fact,
you know, been
deploying people to the border
on temporary details,
you know, hundreds of them at a time
now for the better part of two years.
We have,
over the last two years
been adding holding capacity
at the border.
You know, CBP facilities can hold 7000
more people today than they could
two years ago.
So we have been preparing
I would point out
that, you know, we asked Congress
for $4.9 billion
to help prepare
for the lifting of Title 42.
We got less than half of that
from the Congress.
So we are working,
you know, within the resources
we've been given
and the statutes we have, which are,
frankly, you know, broken
and haven't been updated in decades.
To deal with this challenge that we,
you know, knew was coming
during.
It was almost
2 million undocumented
immigrants were thought to have it
come to us
during the first year of President Obama,
the first 12 months, October to October.
Most of that president
I'm sorry, President Biden
what do you think
the number is going to be in a year?
I mean, do you think this is going to be
the biggest surge
of undocumented immigrants
and migrants coming into the U.S.
ever
Yeah.
So there's little doubt
that the last few years
we've seen, you know,
a surge in migration,
that that has been large
and we have, you know, reached numbers
that we have not previously seen.
That said,
we've also over the last two years,
you know, expelled
more than 3 million
people from the United States,
which is also a record.
So, you know, as
we think about the lifting of Title 42,
you know,
we will return to immigration processes,
which as one of your correspondents
noted, takes take longer.
However, they also carry with them
significant consequences for people
who are removed,
consequences that don't exist
for people
who are expelled under Title 42.
And so we believe that the measures
that we have taken,
including the rule
that was published today,
which put some conditions
on asylum eligibility for people
who don't use lawful pathways, will,
over time,
you know, reduce the numbers
we're seeing at the border.
Does the United States have enough
means
to take care of the potentially millions
of people
who will be in a humanitarian crisis
at the border in Chicago,
in New York and Miami? I mean,
are we going to be able to
to to help these people?
It just seems like
we're already stretched so thin
And that's a great question, Jake.
I would say that, you know,
we have been working
closely with cities
throughout the country
and with NGOs to build capacity
to receive migrants
and to transport them.
But these are the costs
of our fundamentally broken
immigration and asylum system.
You know,
the president has asked
Congress on day
one of this administration
to come together
on work
on a bipartisan basis
on immigration reform.
We have not seen that from Congress.
And as one of your correspondents
noted, you've seen
now these surges in migration happen
under presidents
of both political parties who have tried
to deal with this
through executive action, as we have.
But until we get, you
know, Congress to come together
and meaningfully reform our laws,
you know,
I think we're going to
continue to see these surges.